ايضا من بغداد مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي
ينقلنا عامر الى اجواء هذه المظاهره واهم
ما رفع فيها من شعارات واطلق فيها من
هتافات
عامر نعم زين هذه هي المظاهره الاسبوعيه
هنا في العاصمه بغداد في كل جمعه يكون
هناك جمعه او صلاه جمعه موحده في احد
احياء بغداد حيث لا تصلى الجمعه في مساجد
اخرى وفقط في مسجد واحد تتحول هذه
المظاهره بعد الخروج من صلاه الجمعه الى
مسيره نحن الان في حي الخضراء والمسيره
تتجه الى مفترق العامريه في غرب العاصمه
بغداد اهم الشعارات كما سالت الجميع هنا
يركز على اليوم تحديدا هناك تركيز على
فكره كسر الحصار على
الازمه الصعبه جدا التي يعيشها النازحين
في غزه في ظل هذه الاجواء البارده ولذلك
هناك تركيز كثير من اللافتات الشعارات
المرفوعه على كسر الحصار عن قطاع غزه
ودعمهم من كل مكان وان هذا امر غير مقبول
خصوصا كما ذكر حسن قبل قليل ايضا يتحدثون
عن ترك الاونور بدون دعم وهذا حكم
بالاعدام كما قالوا على الشعب الفلسطيني
طبعا الكثير من الشعارات التي يعني تندد
بما وصفوه المجازر المستمره في قطاع غزه
على مراه ومسمع من العالم بل وبتواطؤ كما
يقولون عربي وعالمي على حد وصف
الشعار العام لهذه المظاهره يعني زين وفي
كل اسبوع يكون هناك شعار عام لهذه
المظاهره الشعار لهذا الاسبوع هو انصروا
اسود امتكم قبل ان تنهش كلاب اعدائكم وهنا
يعني يريدون ان يوصلوا الرساله بان على
العالم العربي والاسلامي ان يقف الى جوار
غزه في هذه المحنه وان تركهم لاهل غزه هو
حكم بالاعدام عليهم كما يقولون وبالتالي
عليهم ان يقفوا الى جانبهم طبعا تندي
واستنكار كبير بالمواقف الدوليه الداعمه
لاسرائيل في هذه المجازر كما يقولون ايضا
من اهم ربما الشعارات التي ترفع هنا هو
دعوتهم للمقاطعه مقاطعه منتجات كل الدول
التي تقف الى جانب اسرائيل في هذه الحرب
يريدون ويرفعون طبعا كثير من اللافتات ومن
القوائم لهذه البضائع التي يجب مقاطعتها
نصره لاهل غزه سواء بكل شيء طبعا ايضا
واضح واضح جدا وجلي امامنا ان هناك دعم
للمقاومه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
ولحركة داف المواقع الامريكيه سواء في
العراق وفي سوريا نعم هناك بعض الفصائل
اعلنت قبل عده ايام بانها علقت عملياتها
لكن الكثير ايضا من هذه الفصائل مازالت
تؤكد بان هذه العمليات مستمره اليوم على
سبيل المثال حركه النجباء اكدت بان هذه
العمليات مستمره ولن تتوقف البنتاجون في
اخر تصريح له قال بان عدد الاستهدافات بلغ
منذ السابع من اكتوبر اكثر من 161
استهدافا المقاومه تقول بانها تجاوز اكثر
من 180 استهدافا ويقولون بان المقاومه
مستمره حتى توقف الحرب على غزه رفي من
بغداد وحسن الشوبكي من عمان شكرا جزيلا
لكما